I know I told you this last week but
once again the Dow Jones has crashed
what is now another 2019 record this
time just over 800 points yesterday it
wasn't just the Dow crashing more than
three percent the Nasdaq fell more than
three percent the S&P 500 fell more than
three percent and it is starting to get
very very ugly in real terms
personally although this doesn't matter
I looked at my mutual fund account last
night something I don't do that often
and it was ugly very very ugly I
recommend most of you stay away from
those accounts if you have them as well
but the economic implications are of
course much more important and drastic
than the personal implications and when
we look at the effect or the non effect
of the federal funds rate cut that we
saw from the Federal Reserve when we see
the continued impact of Donald Trump's
trade war when we see continued
instability in the bond markets every
every day we are getting a little bit
closer to saying we are now in a
recession rather than getting closer and
closer to one and meanwhile maybe most
disturbingly because economic downturns
are part of the status quo but usually
we want to feel good about the person at
the top at least understanding what's
going on if not necessarily being able
to do anything about it
Trump meanwhile is pretending like his
economic policies make sense that
everything's fine unless of course it
isn't fine in which case it's definitely
not his fault it's everybody else's
fault it's Democrats it's Obama it's the
Federal Reserve because they didn't do a
big enough federal funds rate cut his
trade war against China oh that's very
good that's definitely not the reason
for economic instability farmers going
out of business or anything like that
and Trump now personally attacking Fed
Chairman Jay Powell as clueless when
it's of course Donald Trump who has no
idea what's going on take a look at this
trump saying quote we are winning big
time against China I mean that's just
not true companies and jobs are fleeing
they're fleeing the United States prices
to us have not gone up and in some cases
have come down China is not our problem
though Hong Kong is not helping our
problem is with the Fed raised too much
and too fast now too
cut spread is way too much as other
countries say thank you too clueless
jpowel and the Federal Reserve Germany
and many others are playing the game
crazy inverted yield curve we should
easily be reaping big rewards and gains
but the Fed is holding us back we will
win even if you believed this story
which is a completely unbelievable story
who nominated so-called clueless jpowel
to the Federal Reserve oh right it was
Donald Trump himself but personal
responsibility obviously not happening
and this may actually be a real problem
for Trump obviously a recession is a
problem period and I don't want one
regardless of the political implications
that some Republicans are saying you
left these are hoping for a recession to
remove Trump no we have more than enough
evidence to removed from to warrant
removing Trump already we don't actually
need a recession and I'm not hoping for
one but remember that Donald Trump's
rich friends we're all counting on Trump
at least boosting the stock market so
that they could make a ton of money
while lowering their tax rates the stock
market is back down to where it was
about a year and a half ago and they
could continue to look very ugly for the
next year for the next many years are
those trumpets going to keep funneling
cash to Trump's campaign if Trump loses
the stock market gains and actually
delivers losses you almost can't really
even have an economic discussion during
the Trump administration because you
have a completely reckless clueless
petulant child with no understanding of
economics or trade policy or financial
policy sort of feeling around in the
dark and making major policy
announcements via Twitter while blaming
everyone but himself for what's going on
I want Donald Trump to lose in a
landslide in 2020 I don't want it to
happen because of a ruined economy
that's bad for everyone no matter what I
want though it might be what we end up
with at the rate that things are going
and once again we may end up with a
terrible stock market during a
Republican president a sensible recovery
under the next democratic administration
which Republicans will pretend doesn't
exist
followed by Republicans saying it was
really Republicans that caused the
recovery
rinse repeat like bush-obama and as
we've seen many times in the past it
doesn't look good and it is actually
starting to affect Donald Trump's
approval rating let's talk about that
next